ante la comisión de asistencia a los
refugiados decenas de haitianos se
aferran cada mañana a la esperanza de
ser regularizados como la mayoría de
ellos ya pasó varios años en sudamérica
pero su objetivo era llegar a méxico
para estar más cerca de su país natal
con esa meta cruzó nueve países en
pésimas condiciones días atrás la
guardia nacional lo agredió
violentamente a él ya su esposa pese a
eso quiere establecerse aquí
no tengo la idea de irme a eeuu quiero
quedarme aquí para trabajar en méxico
veo que hay trabajo solo espero tener
los documentos porque aquí no podemos
vivir sin papeles como los documentos
que hicieron para visita para pie en las
últimas semanas a cientos de inmigrantes
haitianos han llegado a la ciudad de
mexico y viven en condiciones precarias
romeu son neus encontró lugar en este
refugio dejó haití hace casi cuatro años
y su vida sufrir la violencia de la
crisis política en haití es una
violencia física y moral moral hay pocos
refugios en la ciudad de méxico y todos
carecen de espacio para hacer frente al
flujo de migrantes haitianos en los
últimos días los voluntarios instalaron
camas improvisadas hasta en el techo con
hombres solos ahorita las personas que
estaban en familia lo hemos intentado
moverlas en otro albergue regularmente
tenemos capacidad para 25 incluso hasta
30 quizás está en un día por ejemplo
recibimos 30 personas más las 20 que ya
estaban y al siguiente día estaba en
esas mismas 30 más otras 20 que llegaron
pese a la falta de infraestructura y a
la urgencia de la crisis migratoria el
gobierno de la capital mexicana no tiene
la intención de abrir centros de acogida
adicionales